I joined the Army back in 1995
when I was 17 years old.
If you remember, in 1995,
Oklahoma City
experienced a terrorist bombing
and it inspired me
to do something to help
my community.
My name is Marnie Robbins-
Hoffman.
I was in the Connecticut Army
National Guard.
I'm currently assigned
as a patrol sergeant
at the Yale Police Department.
Having the Yale
veterans community behind us
and with us
walking with us is helpful
because it is a group of people
that have been through
some of the same challenges
that we've all been through.
Veterans Day
has a great meaning to me.
This is a day
for us to remember everything
that we've done,
everything that we've achieved,
and to remember the friendships
and the camaraderie
that we've made throughout
our time in the military.
Most of all, it's a day of
deep appreciation
for everybody that's ever worn
a uniform.